uh we have this is a disturbing story i
want to uh uh let everybody know in
advance that this is a very very
disturbing story that we're about to
talk about um
an anti-abortion nut in her late 20s has
been caught by police
this is really tough
with five fetuses in her house
um this is a real headline i was
convinced when i first saw it this this
must be bogus this can't possibly be
real
but it is all too real and it is
horrifying
and um
this seems like a very very sick person
dc police find five fetuses in the home
of anti-abortion activist lauren handy
people will freak out when they hear the
anti-abortion activists reportedly said
washington dc police found five fetuses
in the home of an anti-abortion activist
on wednesday lauren handy sat outside
her home as officers
brought out coolers containing fetuses
handy declined to tell a reporter
outside her home what was there but said
people will freak out when they hear
metro police confirmed to huffpost that
it found the five fetuses after being
sent to investigate a tip so that means
someone knew
how sick this woman was
and they reported her which is good it's
a good thing that someone reported this
woman
the police statement says upon further
investigation mpd located five fetuses
inside a residence at the location the
fetuses were collected by the dc office
of the chief medical examiner
um
image of the woman sitting outside her
home has been published widely to
twitter
another article on this from nbc
washington
lauren handy is one of nine people
accused of blocking access to a dc
abortion clinic in 2020. so this is
already someone on the radar of police
for her uh i i i don't even to even call
it anti-abortion activism
seems not to actually take into
consideration what it is that these
people do
um police went to 28 year old lauren
handy's basement apartment
and uh investigating a tip about a
possible biohazard material in her house
they collected fetuses it it's just sick
i'm not even gonna doubt can you guys
get it okay you guys if this is
difficult to wrap one's head around did
anyone know
how long did she have them what was she
going to use these fetuses for and
understand one really important thing
here okay
i am guessing if you asked her or other
anti-abortion activists willing to do
this why they did it
they would say it's to prove some kind
of point for the shock value in some
kind of anti-abortion propaganda to
expose the evils of of stem cell
research embryonics i don't know what
they would say but they would have some
justification but understand that by
their own logic these are people
they believe
that these are people
some of them believe at conception some
of them believe it five weeks some of
them believe okay
if you believe that a fetus is a person
you've basically stolen human bodies
from a morgue which is criminal
understand that this is by their logic
and their framework of what they believe
about this issue these are fully human
lives according to them
so this would be like keeping five
dead bodies that again by their that
have been killed by their logic
um these are some
you know
i don't know
are these bates motel twists or
i don't know
um but this is absolutely sick this is
so ba you know the it's sort of like the
fox hosts who argue that they give you
the news and the truth on air then they
get sued for what they say and in court
they go
we're entertainers we're just
entertainers that's it this isn't news
when they get sued
is it going to be an example of the same
thing well listen the these are these
are humans murderer oh but you just got
caught with five fetuses these are
humans right so this it's like having
five bodies from a morgue no no no this
is just this is tissue
that's all it is these people are sick
these people are sick and i'm i'm not
using the t word right what we often
call the domestic you know what we call
them i'm not using it because i just
don't know that it's legally appropriate
but it's pretty damn close it's pretty
damn close what these people do uh to
shift gears and it's very hard to shift
gears from this
i want to invite all of you to uh
participate in our next town hall we are
doing a town hall opening the phone
lines to all of our viewers viewers and
listeners it'll be tuesday april 19th at
6 p.m eastern it'll be live on our
pacman live channel really looking
forward to it really looking forward to
hearing from you guys and i'll i'll have
more reminders coming up let me know
your thoughts about these first couple
of stories find me on twitter
deepakman